♫ ♫
>> Greg: IMAGINE AN INNER
CIRCLE IN HELL WHERE YOU ARE
DOOMED TO FIND THE BIGGEST GROUP
OF YOUR LIFE.
THAT’S WHERE YOU’LL FIND
HILLARY.
>> I WON THE PLACES THAT
REPRESENT TWO-THIRDS OF
AMERICA’S GROSS DOMESTIC
PRODUCT.
I WON THE PLACES THAT ARE
OPTIMISTIC, DIVERSE, DYNAMIC,
MOVING FORWARD.
AND HIS WHOLE CAMPAIGN "MAKE
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN" WAS LOOKING
BACKWARDS.
YOU DIDN’T LIKE BLACK PEOPLE
GETTING RATES.
YOU DON’T LIKE WOMEN GETTING
JOBS.
YOU DON’T WANT TO SEE THAT
INDIAN AMERICAN SUCCEEDING MORE
THAN YOU ARE.
WHATEVER YOUR PROBLEM IS.
I’M GOING TO SOLVE IT.
>> Greg: BEAUTIFUL.
THERE SHE IS AGAIN POINTING OUT
THE PLACES WHERE SHE WON.
IMAGINE A QUARTERBACK WHO JUST
LOST THE SUPER BOWL POINTING OUT
THAT HE THREW NO INTERCEPTIONS.
THAT DOESN’T MATTER.
THAT’S NOT HOW WE KEEP SCORE.
HE ALSO THREW NO TOUCHDOWNS.
THAT’S HILLARY.
SHE BLAMED WHITE WOMEN WHO VOTED
FOR HER TRUMP ON FEAR OF
DISOBEYING THEIR HUSBANDS OR
BROTHERS OR SONS.
WOMEN ARE TOO WEAK TO MAKE UP
THEIR OWN MINDS?
THAT’S NOT THE WORST PART.
THAT’S WHEN SHE WORKED IN THE
INDIAN AMERICAN ASIDE BECAUSE
SHE IS IN INDIA TALKING TO
INDIAN PEOPLE.
THAT’S HOW HER MIND WORKS.
LOOK, INDIANS.
I WILL SAY THAT TRUMP VOTERS
HATE INDIANS TOO.
SO SHE PANDERED.
DIVISIVE IDENTITY POLITICS.
SHE STILL LIVES IN A WORLD WHERE
YOU DON’T SEE ACTUAL PEOPLE,
JUST THE GROUP THEY BELONG TO.
SHE LOOKED AT THE AUDIENCE AND
ONLY SAW THEM.
I WONDER WHERE THEY SAW LOOKING
BACK.
A SORE LOSER?
LUCKILY WHY SHE LOST.
SHE IS SO BITTER, YOU COULD MAKE
AN OLD-FASHIONED OUT OF HER
TEARS.
ALL RIGHT, JUAN.
DON’T YOU JUST WANT HER TO GO
AWAY?
>> Juan: I THINK SHE IS DOING
GREAT.
SHE SOUNDED LIKE SHE WAS TELLING
THE TRUTH.
>> Greg: IN INDIA SAYING THAT
HALF OF AMERICA SUCKS.
THAT’S WONDERFUL.
>> Juan: IMMIGRATION AND
IMMIGRANTS, HUGE ISSUE THAT
BENEFITED DONALD TRUMP IN THE
LAST ELECTION.
>> Greg: AND THAT WOMEN WHO
VOTED FOR TRUMP ARE WEAK.
>> Juan: WHAT SHE SAID IS ONCE
THE COMEY THING CAME OUT, ALL
THE PRESSURE COMING FROM
REPUBLICAN WHITE MEN, THE
BIGGEST TRUMP SUPPORTERS OF ALL,
ON THEIR WIVES AND GIRLFRIENDS.
ALL OF THEM SAID LOW, YOU CAN’T
BLAME HER.
SHE’S GOING TO END UP IN JAIL.
LOOK AT HER.
SHE IS CORRUPT.
I THINK FOR YOU, GREG GUTFELD,
IN THE TRUMP WORLD.
I WOULD SAY YOU NEED HER.
YOU WANT HER.
>> Greg: I WANT HER TO GO AWAY
AWAY.
>> Juan: YOU SAY YOU WANT HER
TO GO BUT YOU LOVE HER.
HOW ABOUT YOU AND NANCY PELOSI.
>> Greg: I LOVE THIS ARGUMENT.
IT IS SO WEAK.
>> Juan: YOU WITHOUT ELIZABETH
WARREN.
>> Greg: THEY ARE IN THIS
UNIVERSE.
IT IS ALL OVER THE NEWS.
YOU CAN SAY I WANTED.
I WOULD LIKE HER TO RETIRE INTO
THE WOODS.
>> Jesse: AND HILLARY DOESN’T
LIKE PEOPLE, BOTTOM LINE.
DOESN’T LIKE HALF THE COUNTRY.
WE KNOW WE CALLED HALF OF THEM
DEPLORABLE.
SHE LOST BECAUSE SHE WAS A
DEPLORABLE CANDIDATE.
SHE DOESN’T LIKE WOMEN TOO MUCH.
SHE DOESN’T THINK MUCH OF WOMEN.
TO ASSUME THAT WOMEN WILL VOTE
FOR SOMEONE BECAUSE OF THEIR
GENDER IS TO REALLY NOT
UNDERSTAND WOMEN.
WOMEN VOTE FOR WHOEVER CANDIDATE
THEY THINK IS GOING TO BE THE
BEST PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
HOW DO YOU KNOW, JUAN OR HILLARY
OR WHATEVER, WHAT WAS GOING ON
AFTER THE COMEY ANNOUNCEMENT.
YOU KNOW THAT HUSBANDS WERE
TELLING THEIR WIVES, DON’T VOTE
FOR HILLARY?
SEE, COMEY?
SEE WHAT YOU DID?
YOU HAVE NO IDEA WHAT’S GOING
ON.
>> Juan: YOU SHOULD DO SOME
STUDYING AND CHECK THE POLLS.
>> Greg: KIMBERLY.
>> Kimberly: LISTEN, YOU AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
YOU ENJOY HIM SO MUCH.
YOU DON’T WANT HIM TO GO AWAY
EITHER.
>> Juan: I MIGHT REGAIN MY
SANITY.
>> Kimberly: I WISH
HILLARY CLINTON WAS A LITTLE
MORE POSITIVE AND THAT SHE
EMBRACED EVERYONE IN THIS
COUNTRY AND WASN’T CONSTANTLY
DEMONIZING AND BLAMING EVERYONE
ELSE FOR THE LOSS OF THE
ELECTION BESIDES YOURSELF.
THOSE ARE SOME FAMILIAR THEMES.
I THINK PEOPLE GET TIRED OF
HEARING THIS KIND OF BITTER
TONE.
>> Greg: DANA, YOU KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED.
SHE LOOKED AROUND AT THE
AUDIENCE.
OH COMMANDING PEOPLE.
LET ME WORK THIS INTO THE
SPEECH.
>> Dana: SHE KNOWS HOW TO DO
IT WELL.
ADULTS PREVENT DEMOCRATS OF ONLY
FOCUSING ON HILLARY.
IF SHE WAS MAKING COMMENTS LIKE
THIS, SHE CAN HAVE A POST
POLITICAL CAREER AND GIVE
SPEECHES THAT ARE MAY BE
INSPIRATIONAL.
I LOST BUT I TRIED.
THERE ARE WAYS TO DO THAT.
THERE ARE STORIES OUT THERE
ABOUT HER WANTING TO PLAY A ROLE
IN 2010.
I HAVE A FEELING HER DANCE CARD
IS GOING TO BE KIND OF EMPTY.
>> Jesse: SPEAKING OF DANCING,